PROFESSOR: So this
brings us to the conclusion
of our Massive Open Online
Course, 10.S9,5 Physics
of COVID-19 Transmission.
So let's briefly review
what we've learned.
We began by talking about
respiratory pathogens,
both bacteria and viruses.
And, in particular,
we focused on viruses
and understood how
they can be transmitted
through aerosol particles
through infected indoor air.
And this includes the
important case of SARS-CoV-2,
the virus that causes COVID-19.
We then went on to use
epidemiological models
and fluid-mechanical
analysis of a well-mixed room
to arrive at a universal
indoor safety guideline
to limit transmission
of the disease.
A very important
conclusion is that it's not
possible to bound
a single variable,
as in all of the current
safety guidelines
from various official
organizations.
So, for example, you cannot
only bound the distance between
people, for example,
6 feet, 1 meter.
You cannot bound only the
occupancy, say, 25 persons.
You can't even bound the
ventilation rate, say,
a minimum of 15 cubic feet
per minute per person.
Or you can't bound
only the time--
let's say 15 minutes
or one hour--
because all of these variables
are, inevitably, linked.
And the simplest way to see that
is through our universal safety
guideline, which
shows you how to limit
the cumulative exposure time,
(N-1)t, which
is a product of the
number of susceptible
people in a room times
the time they're together
with an infected person.
And there are a number
of factors that come in.
So epsilon is a
tolerance you can choose.
And then there are these factors
lambda_V over --
Q_b^2 P_m^2 Cq.
And we can discuss, based on
that formula and our analysis
throughout this course,
the most important ways
of mitigating transition
based on this formula.
So I've, roughly, put
them in order here.
So the first thing is to wear
masks and, in particular,
try to wear good masks.
So these might be
surgical masks, N95s,
but even various cloth
or silk masks, especially
double-layer fabrics,
can be quite effective
because, as P_m goes to 0,
the mask penetration factor,
you can see this bound
gets larger and larger,
like P_m^2.
So a factor of 10%
transmission can still
give you a factor of 100
compared to not wearing
masks in terms of filtration.
That's a very
significant amount.
Secondly, we can
improve ventilation.
And this can be by imposing
faster mechanical ventilation
with more fresh air coming in.
It could also be by opening a
window and turning on a fan.
And that's increasing lambda_a.
We can also try to spend more
time in larger rooms or even
outside, which is,
basically, increasing V
and, thereby, diluting
the air that is present
and all the infectious aerosols.
We can also look at
imposing air filtration.
We've shown that there
is some benefit there.
Although, it might not
be as large as you think.
Even very good air
filtration doesn't
buy you many orders of
magnitude because it's only
filtering some of the
air, but not all of it,
compared to masks, which
are filtering at the source
and at the target and, thereby,
are much more effective.
We can also try to make sure the
occupants of the room maintain
lower activity
levels if possible.
So they're breathing
less heavily.
So they're exchanging air with
the space and with other people
less frequently and
at a lower rate.
We can also try to avoid
vocal exertions, which
tend to lead to much larger
emissions of droplets,
for example, singing being
a particularly bad case,
but even loud voices can be a
lot worse than quiet voices.
So, generally, keeping the
noise in the room down--
I know this will be welcome
news for many teachers--
but, in general,
that is a good way
to try to limit transmission
to keep people calm.
We can also take measures
to try to enhance
the deactivation, the
natural elimination
of the infectiousness
of the virus.
One way to do that
is to maintain
an intermediate, comfortable
range of humidity
from 50% to 80%.
So very dry air turns
out to be worse,
and that is one of the reasons
that viral diseases tend
to be seasonal, like the
seasonal flu, typically,
worse in winter, in addition
to the fact that you're
spending more time indoors.
There's also ultraviolet
treatments that might be used,
which is, effectively, like
another form of filtration.
And then, finally,
we spent a lot
of time talking about the fluid
mechanics of indoor spaces
and of human respiration
and movement,
and those considerations take
us beyond the well-mixed room.
And the main thing
to remember there
is, thinking back to our example
of people who are smoking,
if someone is exhaling right
after breathing in a cigarette,
there's sort of a narrow plume
of turbulent, very smoky air,
which you want to avoid.
And the same thing
is true when dealing
with a respiratory
pathogen. You don't
want to spend a lot of time in
the respiratory jet of a person
who is not wearing a mask if
you don't know if they are sick,
potentially, even asymptomatic.
So that's an important just
general piece of advice,
and we've given some insight
into how to quantify that.
Although, any treatment of
short-range transmission
through respiratory
jets is, inevitably,
dependent upon assumptions
about the activity of the room.
How much are you
turning your head?
Where are people placed?
And so, hence, you can't really
get a universal guideline,
as opposed to this boxed
formula, which is, essentially,
the mass balance
for the whole room.
And that is a
universal guideline.
We've also talked a bit
about types of ventilation.
And, as opposed to ventilation
that seeks to mix the space,
there may be situations
where having high ceilings
and trying to take advantage of
buoyancy-driven thermal flows
that you can sort of target the
airborne aerosols to be sitting
higher in a room where
they could then be removed
by ventilation at the top, which
is displacement ventilation.
That's another strategy
that may be useful.
So these are all different
strategies one can use.
And which one is most
effective or makes
the most sense in a given space
really depends on the details.
And, in order to facilitate the
application of the guideline,
we have provided an
online app and, also,
a spreadsheet, which you
can use to adapt this
to your own space.
And I hope that you will
find the principles you've
learned in this class
useful and that,
perhaps, even you'll
find these tools useful,
specifically, to combat the
transmission of COVID-19
and, in the future, other
respiratory diseases.